denise thousands of regular unemployment
claimants
are wondering their latest payment is
now these deposits typically arrive on
mondays but
many people say they're just missing
dieter says there is apparently an
issue delaying payments for regular
unemployment filers
dieter did go on to add it is working to
resolve the issue as quickly as possible
and that claimant should expect the next
payment within the next two days
now we spoke to one of these claimants
who says he is days away
from having his power shut off and
missing a payment like this
is tough continues to compound that
stress
of trying to find a job trying to deal
with dieter
worrying about christmas i mean i have
five kids here in the household
and i've had to go out for help for
christmas as well
because you know it's just it's been so
rough this year
five children and not also went on to
say he is missing
his fifth lost wages assistance payment
that is the extra 300 weekly
payment dated back from september last
week dear said that payment would take
up to a week and a half up to 10 days
many others like him
are still waiting